[Music]
half of my heart is in Havana he took me
back to half of my heart is in Havana is
something about these matters I know
that how you do it
[Music]
I can do it
I loved it
Oh
[Music]
just graduated first on campus here
[Music]
bump bumper like a
Elsbeth to pay that girl like uncle
found ya
Sally Griffin only get hanging on me
I started cooking on me kinda picking on
me it's a real
[Music]
I was in my heart is in Havana he took
me back to is that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he took me back
ivenna huh
[Music]
my heart is
you took me back to me son
all my
there's something matters matters dinner
will come with it are you to it
[Music]
laughter when I left him gonna feel like
[Music]
it isn't how I Geoffrey just graduated
French on campus yeah fresh is a little
with no manners
fresh reason
like a traffic jam hey I pay that but I
come back it on me
shuttle craving all make it to eat it
not me you waited on me
shut it mommy got the bacon army this is
the Syrian the bacon mommy what black
clothes rage stop me if it doesn't mean
a young that's me I was getting cool ah
baby
I feel my heart is in the van now
it took me back to Eastern
I open my heart is
[Music]
there's something bodies Mendez
[Music]
he will be back
[Music]
what's that believe nation I hope you
enjoyed this video I would love to know
from you who won who sang it better
America or the world leave your thoughts
down the comments below this is a new
potential series that I'm looking at big
shadow to jr. eyes have putting this
first one together for us the goal with
this series would be to try to expose
some new talent I love working with
artists I love showcase and artists and
their abilities so to showcase some of
the talent that's out there on YouTube
these young entrepreneurs singers trying
to build their reputation build their
exposure and us doing that part to try
to give them a little bit more love you
could check out the link to their
channels in the description below so
cast your vote tell me who you think
sing it better America or the world and
also what do you think of this series
should we continue it is it worth doing
again or not is there a song that you
want to hear as the next battle let me
know leaving the comments below thank
you guys so much for watching I believe
in you I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon if you had
to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be like a little beacon hey
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details